esta noche hemos traído principalmente
alma casos colombianos pero es
importante entender que contra estos
crímenes la región ha sido absolutamente
incapaz de actuar con efectividad Por
qué
efectivamente Ángela Parece ser que el
estado no cumple con sus obligaciones de
debida diligencia Mira es muy importante
que las medidas de protección se cumplan
Y esto es lo que principalmente es un
déficit en la región porque ahora que
que está el caso de Erika ponte en
Colombia lo que vimos es que no la están
protegiendo en su lugar de trabajo o sea
le dictaron unas medidas de protección
pero para que hubiera un acompañamiento
medidas de seguridad en su casa y
necesitamos ampliar las medidas de
protección para que también estén las
mujeres seguras cuando vayan caminando a
sus trabajos les cambien las rutas para
que los agresores no se acerquen
a ellas O sea necesitamos que el estado
tenga las capacidades para proteger a
las mujeres más allá de los domicilios
eso es una de las pendientes de las
alertas de género en la región más allá
si se tiene en cuenta alma que
varía la cifra de país a país pero se
puede decir que un buen porcentaje de
las mujeres que han terminado en
feminicidio antes ya habían hecho una
denuncia de habían pedido medidas de
protección que al final no fueron
efectivas pero también alma quisiera
preguntarle sobre las causas del
feminicidio partiendo del hecho de que
son la acción final de un círculo de
violencia y de un crimen que es un total
desprecio por la vida y por los derechos
de las mujeres al final son esas causas
las que nos tienen aquí en este problema
efectivamente Ángela las causas de los
feminicidios se llaman la cultura
machista la cultura machista es algo que
tenemos que erradicar es la idea de que
los cuerpos de las mujeres su proyecto
de vida está a disposición
principalmente de los hombres conocidos
o desconocidos de sus parejas
principalmente no lo que podemos ver Es
que esta ola de feminicidios no va a
parar hasta que los hombres no cambien
de actitud hasta que no haya un un
cambio en sus roles y un entendimiento
de que las mujeres tenemos de los mismos
derechos y un principalmente no un
derecho a la igualdad un derecho a no
sufrir maltrato a no sufrir violencia y
esto pues es algo que que tenemos que
trabajar mucho con las generaciones de
hombres jóvenes yo que me dedico a la
educación insisto les insisto mucho a
los estudiantes que tienen que discutir
su masculinidad que tienen que ser más
autocríticos con lo que significa ser
hombre hoy en día